です私今ですね東京にある
浅草に来ております今日もね平日なんです
けれども
夏休みということでとても
賑わっております
そして海外からお越しになってる方が多
そうですねそんな浅草に今来てるわけなん
ですけれども
浅草といえばそう
人力車
人力車がすごい有名なんですよ人力車って
昔から日本にあるなんかタクシーみたいな
タクシーの人間がこうやってくれる
バージョンなんですけども皆様乗ったこと
ありますでしょうか僕あるんですけれども
ちょっと今日
行きたいところがありまして
浅草からというわけで今日は
浅草から人力車で
ディズニーランドに向かうと何円そして7
分かかるの
皆さんもう行きたいでしょディズニー
ランドで行きたよな行きたいです
ディズニーランドを行きたいんですけども
タクシーで行くのはもう趣がないタクシー
とか電車でディズニーに行くのはもう趣を
感じられないのでせっかく浅草にいると
いうことでちょっと
浅草からディズニーランドに人力車に
向かうとどういう感じになるのか
値段とかも気になるよね
値段も気になるしどれくらいかかるかも気
になるしそもそも人力車のスタッフさん
押してくれる人が大丈夫なのかという
ちょっと人間的物理的心配もあるんです
けどもちょっと今日は浅草からディズニー
ランド行ってみたいと思います人力車で
というわけでこちらが今日の人力車です
そして今日運転してくださる釈さんです
東京駅から若松トラジって言いますか
お呼びさせていただきますよろしくお願い
しますお願いしますよろしくお願いします
なんかこれだけ色が普通の見て普通の人力
車黒なんですけどなんかこれ金ピカになっ
てないですかこれはなんかそういう特殊な
今日初めて聞いてたので金ピカピに山を最
高級なものを準備させていただきました
いつもどれくらい
移動範囲でどれぐらいですか人力車って
主に浅草を
観光ガイドさせてもらった形なので
ちなみに
トラちゃんはその最高距離とかってどんな
感じですか今までのゴールデンウィークの
浅草だけで25キロ30キロぐらいあと
結構すごいですね
今日人力車で
浅草から東京
ディズニーランドまでいいですか
お願いしますお願いします
ちょっとよろしくお願いします乗ってみ
ます
浅草でこれつけてる人いないからね
お願いします
[拍手]
はいじゃあ行きますね
123でお願いします
やばい
横浜のポケモンGOのイベントぶりだはい
ちゃんとシートベルトもついております
これでも暴れて大丈夫なんでありがとう
ございます
すごいでは東京
ディズニーランドまでお願いします
いってらっしゃいます
待ってろミッキー
行ってきます
お願いします
すごい結構スピードがありますね
[音楽]
ディズニーランド向かっております早速坂
ですね
すごいなぁこれ乗ってると日陰があって
ちょっと快適なんですけどトランプさんが
心配だな
[音楽]
めっちゃ快適です
すごい速度だな
皆さん僕ですね今回のこの人力車
ポケモンGOもしております人力車の速度
がねマジでポケモンGOで最適なので
ポケモンGOでポケモン
捕まえながらもディズニーランド向かって
ます
[音楽]
本当に死んじゃうこれは
行ってきます
ちなみに取れた人力車ってタクシーと比べ
てどうなんですかね
何十枚あります
僕ずっと気になってるのが
料金なんですよね
間違いなく
タクシーで確か東京からディズニーランド
タクシーに行ったことあるんですけどそれ
も結構高かった気がするんですよねトヨタ
にそれなりの働きをしっかりさせてるわけ
でそれ相応のお金は多分払うことになるん
だと思いますちょっと気になるなまあいっ
か
楽しければいいです
横浜で乗れたのめっちゃラッキーえ本当
ですか
動画にもしますね
なんか人力車っぽい乗り物でした
[音楽]
はいぜひぜひたくさん飲んでくださいこれ
ね
乗ってる側も結構ね
暑さを感じますね
トラちゃんポケモンGOがエグいやばい
めっちゃタバコ買える
ちょっと眠くなってきました心地よいん
ですよね
はい30分経過しました
僕は全然大丈夫なんですけどもトラちゃん
が心配です大丈夫まだ大丈夫
だ工業高校の皆さんこんにちはもうすぐ
住みたかってことですか
ちょっと30分経ってこの温度なので
コンビニとか寄ってちょっと
プラザに休ませたいですね体力配分とかも
結構
ディズニーまでのポイントになってくると
思うのでちょっと次コンビニ行ったら休ま
せます
[音楽]
捕まります
捕まっちゃったら俺終わっちゃうよここで
よしファミリーマート買った取るじゃん
ちょっと休みましょう
タラちゃんの体力がこの
企画の
鍵を握ってるからちょっとたくさん休ま
せるねありがとう
ございます
お話をかけさせていただいてご案内を
するって感じなのでずっと走るというより
は
声かけをさせていただいて
もう連続はなかなかないです
か結構
痩せたので復活で行ってきます
バイバイ
本当ですか
何で夏にこの企画やっちまったんだ逆に夏
できるともう全シーズン行けそうですよね
これが証明できればオールシーズン一応
浅草からディズニーには行けることは証明
できるはずですお腹は空いてますか
もうちょっと行ったらちょっとしましょう
30分で1/4来てます
[音楽]
左に曲がるとはいはいはい
菜箸っていう
か
割と最難関です
[音楽]
[拍手]
セーブしながら行かないの
[音楽]
父ちゃん次コンビニあったら休憩し
ましょうそろそろ30分近く行ってます
セブンイレブンがありましたここで
ちょっと休憩しますちょっと
[音楽]
休憩して再び出発します
お願いします
行ってきます
[音楽]
そらちゃん帽子かぶります多分全然変わる
と思うんですよね
最高です時刻が1時間半経過しました結構
進んだ気がするんですよねそれじゃあ
大丈夫ですかありがとうございます
頑張れ
風強いです
ついに千葉人力車で東京出た男
[音楽]
ドラちゃんごめんなさい
眠くなってきました
居心地良すぎて
寝ちゃっても大丈夫ですよ
ディズニーが待ってますから
こんなところでは寝られねえぜ
[音楽]
あれ行きます
ヤバすぎる
お願いします
さあすごい坂道に来ましたいやーこれは
やばいぞ
[拍手]
トラちゃん頑張れ
[音楽]
ここが荒川です
荒川アンダーズブリーチ
景色を
[音楽]
なかなか人力車通らなそうな道
初めてですすごい
めっちゃ綺麗オープンさらにやばいですよ
オープンありだなオープンになっちゃった
いやすごいこれは
[拍手]
熱い
温度もですけど
[音楽]
そしてこの橋すごいなこれ思い出になる
なぁ
ちょっとなかなか経験しないことをしてる
[拍手]
うわ
めっちゃ下りだあー涼しい
江戸川区入りました
[拍手]
トラちゃんお腹すきました
そろそろお昼時なので
ちょうどいいところに
我らがソウルフードすき家がありますね
牛丼好きですかすき家行きましょう食べ
ましょうここでお昼休憩します
[音楽]
お昼ご飯食べたので
スタートです行ってきますよろしくお願い
しますあと何キロぐらいですか
[音楽]
はいお願いします
道の駅きました
[音楽]
トラちゃんデザート食べたくないですか
ちょっと
ちょうど今
マックあるんですけど行きますはい行き
ましょう行きましょう
行ってきます
マックシェイクの
マックフィズの瀬戸内レモネードってあり
ますじゃあ
MacBookの瀬戸内レモネード2つで
以上です
はいはい
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
[拍手]
トラちゃん買いました
飼育がなくて
キンキンに冷えてやがります
ありがとうマクドナルドいただきます
もう
ちょいか
待ってやばい
とりあえず目の前にやばい坂がそうなん
ですよさっきよりもやばいね
お願いします
これを分かると
[音楽]
これはやばいな
お願いします
よやばいよやばいが
んばれ
すごいすごい
頑張れ
[音楽]
登り切りましたお疲れ様です
[笑い]
みんな見てくれもうすぐ千葉だ
今ここに1人の男が
浅草から出発し東京都内を出ようとして
いる
たどり着きましたようこそ千葉県へ
来ました
すごい東京都ついに出た
見えるかな東京
ディズニーリゾートの看板がありますもう
少し
頑張れとらちゃんお前ならできる
[音楽]
すごいこの期に及んでこのペース
あれはじめさん何やってんですか
いってらっしゃい
バイバイ
やばい
[音楽]
ぞくれ
止まる
助かっ
[音楽]
た
行きます
[音楽]
めちゃめちゃいい感じですすげー
[拍手]
[音楽]
走れない
かもしれない
[音楽]
迫力ないこれ
握力やばいですね
指と指と吊りそうなんですよ実は
あともう1キロないですよ
見てください看板
東京
ディズニーもうちょっとです
[音楽]
いやこれすごいトラちゃんの
1/10もやってないよ
お願いします
[音楽]
乗り心地いかがですか
すごいよ
じゃあ行きますお願いします
[音楽]
着きました
東京ディズニーリゾートです
[音楽]
ありがとうございましたお
疲れ様でした
[音楽]
というわけでトラちゃんお疲れ様でした
ありがとうございました
というわけで浅草から東京ディズニー
リゾートディズニーランドまで来た結果
人力車で4時間54分かかりました約5
時間ですねありがとうございました
ありがとうございましたただその
休憩とか超猛暑日多分今日よりかかる日は
ないと思うんで絶対
夏が一番強いですよねそうですね
休憩とか結構水分補給こまめにとって5
時間かかったので5時間以内には人力車で
着くことが今回わかりましたどうでした
幸せな時間ですね本当に本当に思ってます
めちゃめちゃ暑かったですやっぱきつかっ
たですよね正直僕最後ちょっとだけやった
んですけど一瞬で熱中症になっちゃった
ぐらいのレベルだったのでマジでトラ
ちゃんすごいですもうありがとうシェフ
さんの力の強さマジで感じましたで
ちょっと気になるんですけど
人力車ってタクシーよりちょっと高いって
いうじゃないですか人が実際動いて
いただいてるのでその今回交通費みたいな
のって何円ぐらいですかねお時間が4時間
54分なのでじゃあ4分おまけで
料金
7万3500円です73,500円
お支払いしますありがとうございます
7万かももうちょっと払いたいぐらいの
凄さを見せてもらったけど
なぁというわけで皆さんぜひ
浅草から
ディズニーランド8万かからないぐらいで
行きますのでぜひ行ってみてください
ありがとうございましたありがとうござい
ました
疲れたので帰ります